fighting's continuing in Sudan's North
Darfur local sources tell Al Jazeera at
least one civilians being killed and six
have been wounded in the province's
capital al-fashir
[Applause]
battles between the Sudanese Army and
the paramilitary rapid support forces
broke out on Thursday
rallies have been held in some parts of
Sudan in support of the army
demonstrations took place in the Eastern
galilef region and in the southern
Khartoum protesters condemned the
actions of the paramilitary rapid
support forces Heber Morgans in onderman
near the capital Khartoum perhaps
slightly astonishingly there are
protests in the middle of a war zone can
you tell us more about that hippo
well hundreds of people came out against
the paramilitary rapid support forces
and voicing their support for the
Sudanese Army but they're also
expressing their frustrations at the
moves of the paramilitary rsf over the
past eight to nine weeks since the start
of the conflict here in the capital
hartum and in other parts of the country
specifically the fact that many people
have been forced out of their homes with
the rsf taking over and occupying those
residents in many parts of the capital
as well as the sexual violence against
women here in the capital Khartoum
people also voiced their anger against
the repeated ceasefires that was agreed
upon by both the paramilitary rapid
support forces and the Sudanese army
they say that these ceasefires gave the
chance for the paramilitary rsf to
expand more into residential areas Force
more people out of their homes and
displays them further and cut off access
to many facilities including Water and
Power in many residential neighborhoods
since the start of the conflict now this
is all have happening as fighting
continues between the two sides the Army
and the rsf with s tracks reported in
the southeast part of the capital by the
Sudanese Army targeting rsf positions
there were also sounds of gunfire here
in the city of onderman so this is all
happening but it shows the level of
frustration among civilians here in the
capital and in other parts of the
country at how far uh this military
operation has been going between the two
sides but also by the atrocities
committed by the rapid support forces
since the start of the conflict
thank you very much indeed